يعني بالفعل لهناك معارك محتدمه بين قوات
فاجنر وبين القوات الاوكرانيه المتواجده
فيما بقي لها في مدينه بخموت هناك تقدمات
لا تنكرها القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
هذه المدينه لكن التقدمات تقول عنها
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه انها تقدمات
ليست كبيره هي تقدمات بسيطه القوات
الاوكرانيه تضطر للتراجع هربا من المدفعيه
الروسيه بالفعل هناك تقدم لكنه التقدم
طفيف ليس بالحجم الذي يذكر لكن هناك هجمات
بصوره مستمره على طول الجبهه الشرقيه
بدايتها من كوبيسك شرق خركيز وكذلك ايضا
فيمان
وافديفكا كل هذه الاماكن تتعرض لهجمات
بالمدفعيه وايضا بالطيران من قبل القوات
الروسيه هناك محاولات مستمره للتقدم من
قبل هذه القوات على طول الجبهات الشرقيه
ايضا القياده العسكريه هنا تقول ان تصدت
اكثر من سبعين هجوما حتى صباح هذا اليوم
منذ الامس وحتى صباح هذا اليوم من القوات
الروسيه وهذا يعني يوضح قوه المعارك
ومحاولات التقدم المستمره من جانب القوات
الروسيه ايضا كان هناك فكره اطلاق لصاروخ
سقط على احد المستوصفات الطبيه ما اسفه
يعني اصابه تعدد من المواطنين كما تقول
الاداره المحليه هناك هناك محاولات لبناء
تحصينات
ودفاعات في شبه جزيره القرم كما تقول
المصادر العسكريه هنا تحديدا للهجوم مضاد
وهذا ما يتضح من مما يراه الاوكرانيون من
تدفق للجنود الروسي في هذه المنطقه تم رصد
عدد من السفن الحربيه الموجوده في البحر
الاسود التي ضاعف عددها وسط حتى الان 9
سفن حربيه هي موجوده بالفعل في مهمات
قتاليه لذلك هذه الجبهه الجبهه الشرقيه
تحديدا لجهه تقدم مستمر من قبل
القوات الروسيه لكن بصفه عامه يمكن قول ان
اوكرانيا يقومون بهجمات مضاده عن طريق
الطيران المسير الذي يستهدف تجمعات للقوات
الروسيه في هذه الجبهه في كثير من المناطق
وايضا تقوم بقصف بالنيران المدفعيه لاماكن
هذه القوات لكن بالتاكيد اتفق احمد ان
التركيز بين القوات الامريكيه عفوا قوات
الروسيه وقوات الاوكرانيه حول باخم
التحديدا ما الذي يعني خساره هذه المدينه
بنسبه الاوكرانيين
احمد اهميتها من طول المعارك التي جرت
فيها هي مدينه او منجم للملح والحجر
الجيري لم تكن بهذه الاهميه ولم يسمع عنها
الكثيرون قبل هذه المعارك التي اشتدت
وتيرتها كون الروسي لم ينجحوا في السيطره
عليها بسرعه كبيره كما ارادوا هو ما
اكسبها هذا الزخم الكبير نحو يتحدث عن
مدينه كان يسكنها سبعين الفا بقي الان
فيها 2000 لا يوجد فيها شيء يتحرك سوى
الجنود من الطرفين الجميله المدينه دمرت
بصوره كبيره للغايه
وجدنا او تحدث لنا المواطئين الذين كانوا
هناك عن ان هناك العديد من
الاناشيد والكثير من العبارات التي تقول
ان بخموت تحب
اوكرانيا حتى ان هناك بعض الفرق الغنائيه
الان يعني تغني لهذه المدينه التي اصبحت
اشهر المدن قاطبه هنا في اوكرانيا لذلك هي
يشبه حتى ان رئيس الاوكراني ذاته يتحدث
عنها بانها قلعه بخموت باتت هامه منعت
بصوره كبيره القوات الروسيه من التقدم
وكذلك لانها هامه لانها اذا سيطر عليها
الروس سيكون هناك الطريق مفتوحا الى
كروماتورسك وكذلك سلوفيانسك هاتان
المدينتان الهامتان لذلك وجود القوات
الاوكرانيه ووقوفها وصدها لهذه الهجمات
المتتاليه والمستمره من قبل القوات
الروسيه يمنع القوات القوات الروسيه من
التقدم السيطره على بلدات اخرى وبالتالي
السيطره على كامل الاقليم وهذا يفسر سبب
استماته القوات الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن
هذه المدينه شكرا